hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I think it's time we brought this series
back welcome back myth chasers if you
haven't seen this type of video before
we are here to test out your myths and
queries in a little game called [ __ ]
night if you want to be featured or have
a burning question leave a comment which
starts myth chasers below and we'll try
out the most intriguing please think
about using code a tomorrow in the store
that would really help but now let's do
this and I'm starting with one of my own
myths myth chasers how much loot can a
shark really eat for this one I put out
a call an hour discard and half a dozen
of us jumped into a custom match and
grabbed a bunch of loot and then we set
up this highly scientific test to
monitor the loot consumption of a shark
any ideas how many they can eat what's
your guess well we quickly discovered
this guy can eat way more than five
slots worth which was the number I was
expecting to be honest so we continued
to give it more and more every time it
looked like it was going to end he came
back for another bite
we'd ran out of loot II got that but and
counted that he ate 21 weapons and 15
launch pads and other consumables so
sadly we can't say for certain water
sharks limit is but this does suggest
the shark is a bottomless pit of loot so
there's only one thing to check now is
the loot still in sight before we open
him up let's bring another myth in bemy
double-oh-seven says myth sharks can be
used as extra inventory space for
late-game why us I like your thinking
it's all about the loot inside said
shark see for yourself
yeah as far as we can tell all the loop
that goes into the shark can be salvaged
afterwards so an endgame shark filled
with extra items could be a great meme
strat for someone are you gonna try it
good luck if you do also whilst we're
making this a random person build Hut
watch in the final circle I like things
like that I salute you whoever made that
masterpiece next myth
[Music]
pora mafia asks what happens when you
ride a shark inside steamy stacks I like
this one as we all know steamy stacks
has the ability to propel characters
into the air and some vehicles too but
what effects will it have on an angry
shark let's do this once I caught a
shark I raced over to the stacks and
jumped right in and this happened the
shark didn't float in the air and nor
did it sink into the purple water he
sought a chilled paddling in the Kevin
Slurpee juice and then suddenly he
decided he wanted to go back into the
ocean but this isn't the end of this
myth did you see what happened to the
player they begin to parasail above the
purple juice but remain tethered to the
shark for a few moments it looks damn
cool and could easily be made into a car
mechanic in the game so that's what
happens when a shark visits steamy
stacks Oh in fact there is one more
thing to report on here
I miss time to jump into the cooling
tower and check out what happened
the shark glitched onto the stack and
jumped around happily weird as heck but
I thought it was cool to see and I'd
show you it anyway I can confirm no
sharks were hurt in this test well
except that one who eventually D spawned
after a few minutes next myth do shark
attacks do more damage if the shark is
glowing a different color well we're
already doing shark myths so let's try
this one too so a standard hit from a
diving shark which hits you straight in
the face is a massive ninety damage I
did this loads of times but the best I
could get was ninety damage it was
usually 60 so then I fed this guy a
golden weapon and tried again and it
still
for 60 I couldn't get that ninety number
one more time so it looks like what
they've eaten doesn't actually affect
how they hurt me
any more shark myths game over one says
myth the spray paint stays on the shark
oh great
now we've got to get close up and
personal to spray a shark this will end
badly
let's try it the plan was pretty simple
Beach the shark and then slow its return
to the water by building around it
here is my first attempt yeah I'm a
total loser
I tried this a few more times and the
closest I got was this spray which
looked like it was on the shark but as
soon as it moved it was really on the
wall behind it so sadly mythbusted that
one would have been a really good one
too Gertie's next myth or vehicle myth
ok Pro duo asks can we use an underwater
boat or chopper ok I think they mean we
want to try and get the boat from under
the water on top of the water and same
with the choppers well this one is very
easy my friend it's as simple as
shooting a single bullet the bullet will
cause any vehicle stuck at the bottom of
the flood to raise all the way to the
surface pretty cool isn't it and this
also works with llamas sometimes there
one shots sometimes they are full health
but if you spot one under the waves you
can claim it I'm not too sure how useful
this all is but if you're stranded in
the storm finding that extra boat or
chopper under the waves could be the
difference between life and death oh
they don't say death do they from life
and elimination so it's definitely worth
knowing also be careful when doing this
because sharks are around and they hurt
so this is a short episode I really did
this to see if you want me to do more of
this in future if not that's okay I know
there's tons of channels that do this
all the time so it's up to you anyway on
screen now are some more of the legends
that have used my code during this first
few weeks of season 3 I am so far behind
on DMS but I will get to you it'll just
take a little longer than I first
thought but I'll get there thank you
very much thanks for watching thanks for
everything just just stay awesome see
you all soon
[Music]